. A lot of hot mikes this week at the NATO
summit in the UK and now Donald Trump has
been caught on one.
So I told you that Donald Trump, after finding
out that other world leaders were laughing
about him, he is a literal laughingstock among
world leaders.
He threw a tantrum.
He left the NATO summit early, but he also
insulted Canadian prime minister Justin Trudeau.
After that happened, Trump was caught on a
recording congratulating himself about the
funny zinger of an insult against Trudeau
calling him to face.
So let's go through it piece by piece first.
Here is Donald Trump calling Justin Trudeau.
Two faced you be the judge about how much
of a biting zinger criticism this was.
Well, he's too fast and honestly with Trudeau,
he's a nice guy.
I find him to be a very nice guy.
But you know, the truth is that, uh, I called
him out on the fact that he's not paying 2%
okay.
And then Trump later really apparently thinking
that that was a great insult.
Caught on a hot mic saying wasn't that so
funny when I called Justin Trudeau two faced,
he didn't do it.
He didn't do it.
It's funny when I sent the guys too.
Oh yeah.
It was super funny when you said he was too
faced.
Right?
Who?
Who else heard it?
Because that was really funny guys.
Did you hear me?
This is cringe-worthy.
This, this is like the kid in school who one
time said something that was like a two out
of 10 on the humor scale and then for weeks
at every opportunity brings it up.
Remember that time when I said that one thing?
Oh yeah, but we're talking about something
else.
Oh yeah.
No, but it reminded me of that time where
I said that really funny thing.
Don't, don't you guys remember how funny that
was that that's what this reminded me of.
This is such an insecure person at heart.
He's giving a blow by blow of just a lame
comeback to remind people of how he really
got the last word and came out on top before
he fled back to his airplane and flew back
to the United States.
What's super clear from this is that Donald
Trump is really embarrassed as he should be.
Now, I know a lot of people say David, he's
not embarrassed.
He's, he's unable to feel shame.
He always thinks he acted correctly.
I think that it's a combination.
I think it's a combination of his delusions
of grander, but he is embarrassed to some
degree.
It might be perceived as anger.
He may even see it as anger, but at this point
it's clear that deep down somewhere in there,
there is embarrassment there and this is all
he can do to fight back and in some sense
it's sad.
In another sense, it is hilarious to watch
it from the sidelines, but the big picture
that I want to mention is that this is so
emblematic of the problems in the world right
now.
World leaders are caught expressing concern
about Donald Trump's bizarre behavior.
In other words, world leaders, when they think
people aren't listening or when they don't
think they're being recorded, they're talking
about how odd and disturbing Donald Trump's
behavior is.
Trump gets hot, put caught on a hot mic and
he's just praising himself for a, quite frankly,
not very funny insult that he told and reminding
people around him how funny it was.
This is a microcosm of everything that is
taking place right now and it can't end soon
enough.